("Legendary" by Welshy Arms)
- [Gary] Sure.
- (inaudible)
- [DRock] I'm gonna go there.
- [Gary] Cool.
- [Woman] There is
coffee, some snacks.
- [Gary] Yeah, exactly.
That'd be perfect.
- Bit over a year ago,
a year and a half--
- Yes.
- I don't know if
you remember me.
- Of course.
- [Man] I thought this
guy, we got to get him.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you.
- It was awesome.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Really--
- [Gary] I'm excited.
Now, what about the
makeup of the audience?
Entrepreneurs, start-ups,
working at businesses,
what's the?
- Mixture.
- I'm sure a lot of people.
Best guess, what do you
think the breakdown is?
(Gary laughing)
Look at this guy.
- [Dick] What's happening?
- [Gary] Hey, brother.
- [Dick] How are you?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- [Dick] Good to see you.
How've you been?
- [Gary] How you've been, man?
Awesome to see you.
Vayner is up to 800 people.
- Come on.
- [Gary] $100 million revenue,
just a real big business.
- [Dick] Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I got to
go do press conference.
- Are you leaving
tonight or are you?
- [Dick] No, I'm here tonight.
- Are you, what are
you doing for dinner?
- [Dick] I don't have any plans.
- Alright. Let's try
to do something.
- Alright. Great.
I'm on right after you.
- Okay, good.
I'll see you in a little bit.
- After I get off,
we'll go to dinner.
- Okay, cool.
- This is--
- I see it. Yep.
- Okay, we can move on.
This is how is the second slide.
- A lot of B2B
people in the audience.
- As well, yeah.
Yeah.
- At least on the industries,
I would say, you know?
- [Woman] Yeah.
Many of them, the marketing,
the digitalization,
there is lots of those
people as well.
- Yes.
- And--
- Okay, let's go.
Here he is the super star.
- Oh we're doing video,
I love it, I love it.
- I love you.
- I love video.
Hey everybody.
How are you?
- This is going
to be so much fun.
- So fun.
- Yay!
- Everyone!
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Thank you, so much.
- Yes.
- Thank you so much.
- Two things, I've got
my introduction for you.
I want to see what you think.
- Okay.
- I have a special request.
- Sure.
- I talked about this with your
team, if you don't like it,
we won't do it.
- [Gary] No problem.
- But this is what I'm
gonna say to the crowd.
I'm gonna say, "Well, how
many of you enjoy wine?"
- [Gary] (laughs) Uh-huh.
- An easy open.
- [Gary] An easy open.
- Well we're going to have one
of the world's most recognizable
wine experts grace our
stage in just a minute.
He's a great example of how
you can turn your passion
into a thriving business.
He transformed his father's wine
and spirits business from
$3 million to a
national success story
selling over $50 million a year.
He achieved this by partly
implementing marketing methods
and social media processes
that have never been used
before in that industry.
Today, he's considered a true
pioneer in leveraging social
media in business.
He's a founder of VaynerMedia,
beautiful producer
of #AskGaryVee,
a YouTube sensation
and here to talk to you about
why smart people dismiss social
media and why they shouldn't.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome--
- [Gary] That's fantastic.
- Gary Vaynerchuk.
- So, super excited first
time back in Finland
in three or four years.
Actually, show a little
clip, Tyler, there you go.
These events are
really exciting for me.
First of all, getting to
different parts of the world,
understanding the different
dynamics, looking at the data
for example Google+
doing well in Finland.
These are different variables
that you don't deal with in
other parts of the world so
really when you travel,
there's a couple KPIs for
me on these things.
One, when I'm speaking at an
event at 5,000 people live and
then 5,000 people on live
stream, got a 10,000 person,
European, international audience
that isn't as familiar with the
strategies and the
ideas and me in general
so that has some upside.
Number two, as you saw earlier,
I don't know how you guys are
editing, running in to old
friends like Dick Costolo,
former CEO of Twitter,
good friend for a long time.
Tonight, the serendipity of
possibly getting dinner even
though we've done business
together for a long time,
I don't think I've had dinner
with Dick in seven years.
That's a KPI.
The five or six people
I've already met outside,
the one guy, you didn't catch it
DRock, ran into some mic stuff.
He's been following me
for 10 years and this was
the moment he got to say hello.
Such a value prop.
That's a very narrow one person,
not scaled KPI but something
that really matters to me.
It's really the way I want to
build and so in a world where
I'm really struggling to balance
do I want to go and give a talk
in Finland for that day that
I have to give up when
I'm operating, what's the
pluses and minuses.
Obviously, with the expansion
of VaynerMedia as I think about
different markets, this is the
opportunity to lay a foundation
of awareness of VaynerMedia
and me which when we open a
Stockholm or a Helsinki office
becomes a real opportunity
three, four, five, six years now
or as I continue to focus on and
I know that we addressed this
in the last episode, what if the
brand that I buy is not only
doing 40% of its business in the
US but happens to be doing 50%
of its business in the Nordics.
It's nice to have a presence,
an understanding,
a taste for the marketplace.
So there are very, very, very,
very, very few things
I do by accident.
- [André] Gary Vaynerchuk.
(crowd applause and cheers)
- Thank you, Finland.
I'm super excited to be here and
really very honestly I'd like to
get to the Q&amp;A portion
of this pretty quickly.
I wrote a book called
#AskGaryVee because I do believe
that these kind of events are
incredible and and a lot of very
smart and special people come
and pontificate and what have
you but the interaction is the
single greatest way to get deep
instead of wide.
I think at the end of day for
everybody that has decided to
come to this conference
there's tangible things we want.
There's something we want and
that's actually where
I want to start.
Actually, you know what?
Let's start with this.
Before I go into this, by show
of hands how many people here
have no idea who I am or
anything about my spiel?
Tell the truth, raise 'em.
(audience laughter)
That fuckin' hurts.
- Love when people say, "Gary,
you always talk about a lot of
"work but I work smart."
I go, "Rick, I work
smart and hard.
"Now what, asshole?"
(audience laughter)
- So you're right.
I'm a very big believer that if
you were sitting in this room
and you're trying to achieve
great things it's very hard to
do that in a five,
seven, eight hour workday.
It just is.
Somebody's gonna work 9, 10, 11
and that's very competitive but
family, interests everybody
should live their lives the way
they want to but if you want to
build something big, if you want
to create a big business, hard
work is the first, second and
third part of the formula.
How many people here
own their business?
Raise your hand.
A lot.
So listen, a lot.
One more time, high.
Okay, here's the most
important part and
I'm really glad
I got to say this.
Everything I just talked about
so many of you are gonna say
I don't understand this.
I didn't grow up with this.
I don't know this.
If you own your own business,
don't you think it makes sense
for you to take
20 hours to either
read or watch videos on
how to place Facebook ads,
how to place Instagram ads,
how does LinkedIn work,
what is Medium.com?
When you have the audacity to be
an entrepreneur and own your own
business and want all the riches
and great things that come with
it you need to put in the work.
I promise you if you look at
your eight hours every day,
two to three of them you're
spending on dumb shit.
You're spending
it like it's 1994.
Take that back go to
YouTube and Google,
search how to place
Facebook ads,
how does Snapchat work,
does Instagram work
for B2B SaaS.
Whatever it may be,
spend 40, 50, 60 hours.
Do because the biggest thing I'm
concerned about, one more time
show of hands, business owners.
The biggest concern I have is
that you're gonna hire somebody
and you have no idea
what they're doing.
You have to be the best
person in your organization.
When I stand in front of
VaynerMedia, it's 800 people,
very young, sharp, best in class
and when I stand in front of
them and say "I'm the
best at social media."
Me, the old guy, the
fuckin' uncle, right?
(audience laughter)
I'm the best,
I'm the best practitioner.
- [André] And the eight guys who
are Finnish here who identify.
- [Gary] That's right.
And so to me, you have to
be the best executor in
your organization.
This is communication and
communication drives everything.
- [André] Thank you so much.
- Helsinki, thank you.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
- Hi, my name is André Noël
Chaker and I'm the moderator of
the Nordic Business Forum
2016 and Gary is by far the most
energetic speaker we've
ever had at this event.
He was tremendous,
he was on fire,
he's an inspiration for
me personally.
I'm all over the social media
here in Finland as a speaker,
as a writer and as a performer.
He has given us
belief in social media
as a catalyst for stories,
as a catalyst to
touch people's lives,
make a difference.
Thank you, Gary.
- [Gary] It's the whole game.
Social, digital is easier to
measure sales than traditional.
What's interesting about where
she went with that, and she's
exactly right why Facebook is
uniquely different is it's so
effective at selling but the
people that really understand
Facebook the best, the fact that
FinnAir can make a 4:37 video,
run it on Facebook and if it
emotionally hits the audience,
it's better than television in
it's prime is remarkable upside.
The problem is, and she knows,
in her organization they want to
see the ROI because it's new.
- Yes.
- And so, on television they'll
run a 30 second video and spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars
with no care in the world.
But to do the same thing on
Facebook where they can be far
more effective, there'll be
scrutiny because it's new.
- Swedish business magazine.
- Okay.
- It's gonna be 20 minutes.
- [Woman 2] 50 volunteers.
- [Gary] Yes, I see a lot.
- [Man 2] This kind of thought
leadership, which you kind of
also, (inaudible).
How would you describe the
importance of social media in
building thought leadership?
- I think it's the quickest
path to thought leadership.
Much to the question that Alexis
had, you know, I lived a world
five, seven years ago when my
biggest dream was that the
Wall Street Journal and
Fast Company and Inc.
and Fortune and
Forbes would cover me.
Now, I produce content on
Facebook and on Medium that they
ask me to have the rights to use
for distribution so I flipped it
and it's the lowest cost,
quickest path to thought
leadership but
there's a problem.
There's a naïveté in this
conference and the world that
just 'cause you talk,
people are gonna listen.
You actually have to,
back to journalistic skill sets,
my belief in thought
leadership is very simple.
It's never been better to have a
chance to be a thought leader.
- [Man 2] So what's the one tip,
how you make
people listen to you?
- Be good.
(group laughter)
It's never been easier to be
a thought leader and it's never
been harder because
you're being exposed.
People used to live
their life saying,
"If that editor
would've just hired me,
"I would've done great."
Now, prove it.
Show me.
The the punchline is there's
very few thought
leaders in anything.
There's very few
celebrities 'cause it's hard.
All of us would be thrilled to
make $20 million a year taking
a picture with products.
Maybe it's not your style but
theoretically I think we can all
agree it's not the worst life
to be an influencer,
take a picture, you know,
and make money that way.
The problem is go and do it.
So you know a lot of times
people say to me like know,
"Gary, you're so lucky."
I'm like, "I'm not lucky.
"It took a lot of work
and it took skill."
The great benefit I had was
I spent 15 years building an
actual business before
I decided to be
a thought leader.
All these 22-year-old thought
leaders on social media is a
very big farce.
Why would I listen to
somebody who hasn't executed?
Right?
And so, to answer your
question be good enough.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
("Roxk" by D Press)
In here?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Need to be their
head of social media but they
themselves don't understand
it and that's a bad situation.
So what I would say
is educate yourself.
Know what this is, then make a
smart hire because you know and
then build the
department around it.
- But if you Googled, I'd
imagine you'd find an incredible
amount of good advice.
- Good and bad, right?
- Good and bad, yeah.
- You gotta put in the work.
If you own a business or
if you're the CEO of a big
business, you've got to put
in the 50 hours of reading and
listening and watching,
it's like anything else.
You had to learn how to drive.
You had to learn how to walk.
You have to put in the work.
- Now you got to learn
how to use Snapchat.
- Yes, right.
And it is a funny way of saying
you have to understand how the
world is communicating.
You can't just show up and
not understand the shift.
And again, like I've been saying
the biggest problem is it's
so big. This is big.
What you and I, we're
lucky the three of us.
The last 60 years were the same.
Radio, television, newspaper.
It was the same.
You have to go back to ancestors
that weren't, aren't
alive anymore.
If you and I, DRock and
everybody watching had our
great, great, great,
great-grandmother here
she would explain.
She would say, yes then
they invented the radio.
Or the telephone.
This has happened before.
There were people who
lived without a telephone.
They wrote letters.
Yes and when the telephone
came, go read the articles.
Western Union said that the
telephone was a fad and
would be gone in three years.
And so, I'll give you my number
one thing that's a problem in my
opinion that will not work out
well for America kids today six,
seven, eight, nine years
old, every school, every sports
organization in America,
everybody gets a
trophy and a prize.
Devastatingly bad.
Very bad.
That's just not life.
Listen, I'd be thrilled, by
the way, on theory if you read
Marxism, like if you
read it, I love it.
Theoretically, it's great.
By the way, as hungry
and competitive as I am,
I have a very basic principle.
I want to build the biggest
building in town but I just want
to build the biggest building.
I think in America too many
times back to what you're
referring to a lot of people
tear down everybody
else's building.
I love fair, my biggest problem
with capitalism is in America,
I hate old, white, rich dudes.
I'll tell you why.
Here's what they do.
They fight a lot of times and
work hard to master wealth but
then when they're old and
they're tired, they want to use
that money to keep it.
- [Man 2] Secure it.
- [Gary] Correct and to me
you got your money because
you killed the other old guy.
So to me if you love capitalism
you have to love it
at your own expense.
- [Woman 3] Yes.
- [Gary] When my friends win,
when Dick is a good friend,
I'm thrilled when Dick becomes
the CEO of Twitter and
makes lots of money.
I'm thrilled when Travis invents
Uber, Travis is my friend,
I knew him
pre-anything 'cause they won.
They deserve it.
And too many people
try to pull down.
- [Man 3] Go Jets!
- Go Jets, baby.
- [Man 3] Have a good one.
- [Gary] Thank you
brother, good to see you.
- [Woman 4] What an
amazing day, huh?
- It's been a great day.
- Gary, thank you,
Gary again for this.
Very Finnish thing.
- [Gary] My man, real pleasure.
Thank you for everything.
- [Man 4] Yes, thank you.
- [Gary] Yeah, take care.
- [DRock] How's your day going?
- Good.
("Runway" by Pell)
- [Gary] Yo.
Set up a call when
I land tomorrow.
Let them know that I'm overseas
and not getting everything in.
Okay.
Yep.
They found a hotel on the way to
the convention center, I jumped
in showered and just
went on stage, spoke and
just went right
back to the airport.
Kuwait was insane.
It was--
- You know you're bragging
about insanely sick things.
- Yes. I know.
My infatuation and love
for America is so extreme.
When you have the
context to know.
It's a totally different thing.
- This is all I'm seeing.
- Which way is up there?
- Providing rental
housing like airBnB.
- Yes.
- So you can rent online.
- And give further notice.
- That's right.
- We're doing that already.
Started this year.
- Love it.
- 750 agreements already.
- That's fantastic.
- Now trying to find
a way to cheaply--
- Scale?
- scale it and
make it really--
- Ready to go? Coming?
- Now we have to rely on photos.
- Yes, and then video, yes.
- And 3D.
- It's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen.
Good to see you.
Ready? Scott, you ready?
Are you camp?
- Camp, yeah.
- Let's go.
- [Man 5] Yep.
- Thanks for--
- New York next week.
- Are you really?
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- My friend, nice to meet you.
Thanks for hanging out.
- Yeah.
Can we take a picture?
- Yes. Sure.
- Shit, it's cold.
(laughter)
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- One more.
- [Gary] Thanks for
the hustle, guys.
Good luck to you.
Hope I see you soon. Cheers.
("Calais" by Okiem Warmann)
You know what's
so funny, Peter?
This is not connecting our last
two conversations, the one thing
I'm most scared about is
being bothered at a Jets game.
- [Dick] Alright.
- My friend.
Real pleasure, great to see you.
I'll talk to you soon.
- Alright. Give me a hug.
- Real pleasure.
Scotty, great to see you, man.
- [Scott] I'm gonna go
try and grab a drink.
- Are you? I'm gonna go crash.
Take care, man.
- [Dick] We're going up.
See you, Scott.
- [DRock] Bye.
- [Gary] Love you. Mic.
(bird tweets)
- Give me just like 10 minutes.
Awesome, yeah.
Thanks, man.
How are you?
- Luke.
Hey man, how are you?
- Good.
- Want to take a picture?
Thank you.
- The thing,
hustle, the animation--
- [Gary] Yes.
- You saw?
- [Gary] Yes, I did see it.
It's awesome, man.
Real pleasure.
- I didn't have the
conference ticket but I'm here.
- [Gary] I'm glad.
- [Man 6] You have some advice
for two 16-year-old entrepreneurs?
- [Gary] I mean, the only thing
that I think maps for every
16-year-old
entrepreneur is patience.
The biggest mistake a
16-year-old entrepreneurs make
is they want things
to happen too soon.
You have so much time.
I mean it's insane
to me to think about
how much time you actually have.
If you doubled your age,
you would still be eight years
younger than me.
You know what I mean?
And when you think about it
that way, you have so much time.
So I think the biggest thing
I would tell you is use
your advantages.
So you don't have
experience but you have time.
What that means is put yourself
in a position where you're
learning and
leveraging now not cashing in.
You know?
Don't, you don't
need the money yet.
You don't need the fame yet.
Build the foundational pieces
that will make you successful.
Be patient.
Spend time around people
that have been successful.
Go look at different things.
You can commit to seven
years of just learning and
still be young as fuck.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- [Gary] You know?
You have time.
Time is your asset.
So patience.
- [Man 6] Great, thank you.
- [Gary] Awesome, man.
Real pleasure, good
to see you again.
- [Man 6] Can
I take a selfie, please?
- [Gary] Yeah, for sure.
- [Man 7] I have one question.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man 7] If you feel like
you're stuck in your present,--
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Man 7] what do you suggest
is the main thing to
do to move forward?
- [Gary] To do something
that breaks the pattern.
Something extreme.
- [Man 7] Yeah.
- [Gary] Just get on a train and
go away for a week or
something different.
You have to break pattern.
It's pattern recognition.
It's people get into ruts
and you just need to find
something to break it.
Even I did it with Wine Library.
I was building a business.
I was like, wait a minute,
I'm not 100% happy,
I started a video
show on YouTube.
It wasn't like I went to Africa.
I just broke the pattern,--
- [Man 7] Yeah.
- [Gary] in an extreme way.
I started a new pattern.
And so, start a new pattern
but you might now like it.
Do it for 30 days and if you
want to keep doing it, go,
and if not then start a
different pattern.
Pattern break up.
(light music)
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] The rest of
the world is on call.
The rest of the
world is on call.
Finland brought it.
What an amazing trip.
Been a great trip.
As we continue to travel, people
are gonna have to step up.
Great people,
great conference, great time.
(light music)